I'm very proud to present Stephen
Wolfram the founder and CEO of Wolfram
research the creator of Mathematica
Wolfram Alpha and the Wolfram language
also the author of a new kind of science
an elementary introduction to the
Wolfram language and most recently idea
makers thank you well it's nice to be
here for the seventh time I guess we
started doing these data summits because
we had just built we just released wolf
malphur and we had been working with
kind of a very broad spectrum of data
providers and we had quite a selfish
reason for starting these estimates
which is simply that we wanted to meet
all the people that we've been working
with and we also figured that people
would be interested to meet each other
well we've been we've kind of kept this
as a small meeting all these years
because we think it's really interesting
for people to actually have a chance to
individually interact with everybody and
I hope you'll manage to do that I always
enjoy meeting with with you all so I
it's become sort of traditional that I
start off this conference by talking
about my kind of evolving view of the
data universe so I will try to do that a
bit this morning so as a company we're
kind of always interested in data as a
path to knowledge so to speak not not
just as an end in itself we've gotten
better and better over the years at
schlepping around increasingly large
amounts of data within the various
systems that we build but we actually
want to do something more than just slap
the data around we want to genuinely
make it mean something make the data be
computable kind of that the goal is that
we've had from from the beginning of the
WolframAlpha project for example is if
there is data that exists in the world
that can in principle answer some
question then make it automatic to
actually get that question answered from
the data have it be the case that that
the data is computable to the point
where if there is some computation that
can be done from this data have it be as
automatic as possible to do that well
Wolfram Alpha itself has been sort of
the flagship example
being able to do this I think it's
introduced a lot of people in the world
to this idea that you can have data that
is computable not just a blob of data
and it's interesting to see that that
it's now seven hundred years since
welcome alpha came out it it remains an
absolutely unique some might say a crazy
project to have considered doing but it
remains an absolutely unique object in
the world well we tried to really
collect together thousands of different
domains of data and make them computable
I mean the basic idea of malphur is
people send in natural language queries
and at this point for the the queries we
actually see on the website we're in the
high 90% success rate in terms of
actually understanding the natural
language which is input we turn that
natural language into an underlying
symbolic representation then we compute
the answer to whatever question is
defined by that symbolic representation
using the curated data that we've been
collecting over the course of the last
many years and and then the result is to
generate automatically generate a report
of things that we think people might
find interesting based on the question
that they asked has turned out to be
really important to generate that whole
report rather than just say the answer
is X people seem to find it very useful
to sort of contextualize the answer and
see all those plots and related kinds of
things well at this point one of the
things that we had to build in the
Wolfram Alpha project was a whole
pipeline for data curation data curation
is a strange art which some of you I
know practice we've the endpoint of our
data curation is kind of an algorithmic
model of data it's not something where
we're just dealing with the ontology of
data in some sort of static form it's
something where we're really having to
turn the data into something that can be
computed from and to not only deal with
data but also deal with methods and
models and algorithms and so on and
insert expert knowledge along the way I
think it's a general principle that I've
noticed with curation is that unless
there is some expert on that particular
kind of data involved in the process you
simply will not get the
answer at the end well the results with
Wolfram Alpha is that it's been out on
the web for about seven abit years now
billions of billions of queries have
gone through the system some of them are
students doing math homework it's pretty
universally used for that chemistry
homework as well now and physics I
suppose and that's it's kind of nice to
see the next generation really it's
remarkable to me that I ran into people
you know high school students and so on
and they all know my name that's a
little bit surprised there's an actual
person behind the whole thing but that's
some the so that that's one kind of
community there are lots of people who
use well from Alpha who are just sort of
curious about data there are also plenty
of professionals policymakers other
kinds of people who use Wolfram Alpha to
make real decisions we certainly do
around our company and so on well that's
the public wolf now for the people sort
of see all the time on the web there's
also the Wolfram Alpha API we're
actually just coming out with a new
collection of api's full of malphur that
are both easier to use and more flexible
and than in the past but the api is used
in lots of places for example it's used
in Siri to provide the knowledge behind
the Syria intelligent a system that's
used by Samsung it's used now in
Comcast's Smart TV stuff used by NASA in
some public information sites lots lots
and lots of places lots of strange
products and and interesting products
that that need computational knowledge
and use the wolf now for API and use the
the many different kinds of data sources
that the wolf alpha is based on then
there's a whole nother world of wolf
alpha which is the corporate orphan
alpha lots of appliances that are
essentially private versions of Wolfram
Alpha out there in the world some of
them are essentially private copies of
the public Wolfram Alpha there now lots
of completely custom wolf mouths --is
that typically mix corporate data of
some organization with public data and
allow the same kind
natural language query mechanism and
report generation from data of all sorts
and there now as a big very big retail
deployment that just went live that
that's making use of the natural
language understanding stack of both
malphur that I suspect a a decent
fraction of people here will end up
because of the retail world using in
some way or another but probably not
knowing it well so so Wolfram Alpha is
is kind of it's it's goal is to provide
sort of consumer level drive by access
to computable data as in there's no
documentation you just go to the website
and you know start to start computing
things and that's some that's been
that's been really interesting because
it's it's a place where people who would
otherwise not have any access to
sophisticated data and sophisticated
computation can just go here and start
start playing with things but this the
the kind of the the drive-by approach to
to computational knowledge is very
useful if you have a quick question to
ask the thing that we I've been
interested in for a long time is what
happens if it gets a bit more
sophisticated than that how do you
represent what you're trying to ask how
do you get your computations done and
we've been building now for basically 30
years a technology stack that is is now
the Wolfram language which is sort of
the the our solution to this this issue
and and kind of the the way this has
evolved Mathematica well I I started
building this actually thirty years ago
this month and the the first kind of
instance of all of this was Mathematica
which came out in 1988 which is widely
used in the kind of R&D world and
education the Wolfram language is is a
more recent thing that really came from
merging Mathematica and the ideas and
content of Wolff malphur together with a
bunch of new ideas about deploy
in the cloud and so on and now the often
languages is the basis of our whole
technology stack which means for example
that Mathematica basically is the
Wolfram language deployed to that
particular kind of customer base for
technical computation so the idea of the
Wolfram language is it's a
knowledge-based language it's a it's a
language typically when people build
computer languages they have a pretty
small language that really is just
providing the basic operations that
computers have built into them together
with a certain amount of bureaucracy
management for dealing with large
programs typically in modern times but
the core of languages is is typically
very small doesn't the language doesn't
really know very much there are often
collections of libraries that exist that
have been built by all kinds of
different people that implement
particular kinds of functionality my
goal with Wolfram language was to do
something which might be considered
quite crazy bold whatever you call it
which is to have a language where as
much as possible as built into the
language where to the to the greatest
possible extent the language already
knows how to do computations it knows
about the world that knows about data
and so on and to have a language where
we're in a sense the language is not as
small as possible but as large as
possible and that's what we've made
building for the last for the last 30
years the the thing that and that there
by now there are many many different
different categories of computation and
knowledge that are built into the
language I think the thing that's been
interesting at a practical level is some
of what we've done with the modern
orphan language is sort of made possible
by the cloud and by the kind of hybrid
model that we have running between
desktop and cloud because in the cloud
we can store all of our terabytes of
data and have them be accessible whether
one is using the language directly in
the cloud or whether one's using
language on desktop or even an embedded
device and so on but we can have all of
that knowledge of the world although all
that data
in effect as if it is within the
language but actually it's it's always
being being downloaded from the cloud
and so on so something that is actually
so languages runs on all the sound
desktop machines and and and also purely
through web browsers in the cloud a new
thing actually just this week is the
release of our private cloud version
where you can take the whole card
infrastructure that we built and run it
as a as a separate private cloud on
separate hardware or in a virtualized
system or whatever else that's that's
just new this week well so as I
mentioned the the the in the form of
Mathematica what we've done has been
used for a long time in the R&D world so
the big thing that's now become possible
with Wolfram language in addition to
having sort of the full knowledge from
what malphur built in is that we've made
a very serious effort at making things
deployable on a production scale and
that seems to work really well because
there are a lot of production
deployments that are now rolling out
we've done some ourselves and many other
people are now doing them it's it's
pretty cool to be able to use our
symbolic language to create an API in
just one line of code to create an API
that does something quite non-trivial in
one line of code and then have it
actually run with a million users
against a cloud and have that all
actually work and you know our goal my
goal in general has just been to
automate everything as much as possible
and it's always satisfying in our own
fairly small company my sort of
optimization for building my company has
been automate things as much as possible
so you can use machines instead of
people and that's been something that
has been sort of spectacular to watch
when it comes to a lot of these kinds of
deployment capabilities because we've
had some large group of people that's
been doing something and then we
gradually automate that process and then
that no longer takes people and those
people can go go work on something else
well
so let's let's talk come I should
actually start up alive I can't can't I
can't do a talk without doing actual
live coding kinds of things so let's
talk about kind of how one accesses
things like data in the language so I
mean and you know in in our standard
language which I'm sure you have all
seen you just sort of talk to the system
and do things one of one of the things
that term is important is in dealing
with data in the language is the ability
to mix natural language with precise
with the precise symbolic language so I
type just NYC and it knew that was New
York City it probably had some other
disambiguation is okay there was only
one there for this this is an entity in
our system and we can go and ask for
various properties of that we can say
what's the population of that or we
could say I don't know what's the you
know distance from let's say the
distance from New York City to let's say
LA and probably LA will have more
disambiguation here yeah okay it's got
various other possibilities and we can
go ask that and it will give us the
answer or we could take you know we
could take this and we could say show us
say we could just get some map here
could say make a disk around Los Angeles
that's some let's say a thousand mile
disk around Los Angeles and so this is
this is our kind of knowledge-based
language in action there's the the map
and so on well so there you know lots of
kinds of data that we're dealing with I
don't know let's pick a let's pick a
random thing let's say let's pick a
person okay man a I guess there may be
some other my gosh there's a network
service called Monet as well okay there
so there's a person and we can say you
know what are the notable artworks by
that person and now it'll go and go find
what we know about that we can say let's
take the first let's say ten of those
that's
let's get let's get images of those
artworks okay there we go
now we can go and say you know we can
take one of these images we could use
that we could do a bunch of processing
on that image let's say where I could
say you know do edge detection on that
image or for example I could say
actually now I'm curious to try
something here let's see what happens if
i if i take that image and i feed that
to our fancy machine learning stack this
may do something terribly horrifying but
this let's see what some okay not so bad
so it's trying to identify the most
salient object in that picture and it
decides it's a sale so or we could go
ahead and you know take this data here
and let's just take that data and let's
say we want to make a something like a a
3d chromaticity plot where we just look
at the at the use of color in color
space with those pictures so this is the
kind of thing that we can kind of
routinely do in sort of a
knowledge-based language like this so we
could we could for example what's
another thing we could do that would be
fun let's just take we could take and
take those pictures and what would
happen if we did this um I could say
make a nearest-neighbor graph see what
happens that wasn't so exciting let's do
a nearest-neighbor graph where we say
vertex labels so this is now going to
use um let's try that wasn't there so
what this was doing was just taking
those pictures and putting them on a
graph based on on which pictures were
considered to be nearest according to a
nearest neighbor criterion that was as
automatically applied to images that's
based on a machine learning system that
is using feature vectors from these from
these various images well okay so there
are lots of lots of kinds of things that
you can do I mean another example where
we're sort of mixing different kinds of
data let's say we find zero elevation
data let's say of a geo disc
let's say mount everest and let's go
let's say we want to do a hundred miles
around mount everest see what this does
so this should should retrieve a certain
amount of geo elevation data now i can
say make her 3d list plot see what
happens there that should see what it's
doing there we go oh it's quite
mountainous there i guess we knew that
um so there's a there's a fine 3d 3d
plot and for example one thing that's
actually just new is we can now say take
that and use some fancy computational
geometry to actually turn that into
something which is 3d printable and so
if you've got a favorite mountain or
molecule or whatever else you don't know
how long that will take for something
for something that rough and mountainous
but what this will do is turn that into
an appropriate piece of 3d geometry and
I think by default it will send it to
one of these FedEx you of a printout
type 3d and 3d printing services um
maybe it will take it a while to do all
those mountains I'm not sure well
alright let's let's go up on this this
is this is I should have I should have
picked two um less less mountainous area
or less some or smaller radius but
anyway it gives some idea of the type of
thing one could do let's talk about
other geometric kinds of things so and
talk a little bit about sort of the
frontiers of data curation so one kind
of data curation is getting
socio-economic data for example where
it's a big table of numbers and so on or
getting data on you know flags that
people use or something which are which
are simple images kind of one of the
frontiers for us of data curation is
curation of things like 3d objects so an
area where we've been doing a bunch of
data curation is human anatomy so for
example if we do let's say we'd say
something like this okay that's the the
left humerus let's say we say anatomy
get well let's actually just take that
and let's say I want the mesh region
associated with that this will now give
me a 3d mesh object which is that
particular bone and I can do
computations on it for example here I
could just say something like take that
and find the area of that bone so it's
gonna be the area or in square meters or
I could take that and I could solve some
differential equation to to work out
some stress and the bone or something
like that or I could say you know I can
there's a kind of complicated hierarchy
of structures in anatomy for example and
here I'm saying making a Natalie plot of
a left hand and there's there's the
results and you can take about apart all
the bones and so on and do computations
on it so that's sort of an example of a
kind of data curation and what what's
needed there there's a this is kind of
complicated case because there isn't a a
standard human so to speak and so this
is something where one has to well it
has to kind of tease out how one gets a
standard human where all the bones fit
together and so on and we've been
working with with folks to do this
another kind of area of curation that's
a little bit unusual is language
curation so so we have a thing we always
call linguistic curation which has to do
with knowing you know when you type a
term like Apple for example you know
what what is that okay is it a financial
entity or is it a food type or is it
something completely different that's
that's one sort of form of linguistic
curation and we end up that the sort of
simplest case of that is entities
millions and millions of different kinds
of entities and knowing their names and
so on and another another type of
linguistic curation entities are the
easiest next is properties and the
combination of entities and properties
as always is always nasty the and that's
and then there's sort of algorithmic
questions that you ask about those
things it's always the reason it gets
nastiest because things don't factor
very well it's not the case that you
always say this entity that property
there are lots of
of language in which those things get
combined and that there all has to be
kind of teased apart but another type of
language curation it's just the
different languages of the world and so
for example we've been increasingly
trying to collect information on all all
languages that have at least any kind of
written form and so here let's see what
happens if I do this okay so we've got
some we can get hello and a bunch of
different languages here and and you
know we can again the whole thing is is
computable so for example I might say
it's a good thing I could do here I
could just say let's get all the values
of all those let's say flatten it all
out and let's for example let's say yeah
let's just get the characters from all
those different languages flatten them
and that's maybe get a word cloud of
what what letters are what what
individual characters are the Communists
in in the word hello in a few hundred
different languages so that's kind of
the types of things we can do or we
could say you know we know for for many
different languages many different kinds
of word lists I don't know we could say
you know let's let's get a list of
common words and let's say Russian for
example and now we could for example say
let's let's make a word cloud of what
the what some what the most common first
letter is in in in Russian words in a
dictionary for example that's the type
of thing that we can we can now easily
do so lots of different kinds of data
curation going on I mean that you know
you can for example another slightly
unusual type would be curating geo
projections so for example I don't know
what some of these are but let's let's
just take a let's take a random let's
take a random sample I'm probably I'll
probably regret this but anyway let's
let's just say a random sample of let's
say 10 geo projections and now let's say
I'll make a Geographics
range is all your projection is each of
those different projections and now let
me just try and make pictures of my gosh
okay well I told you I'd probably regret
that some of these projections probably
aren't projections of the Hollow Earth
okay there we go boy there's some weird
ones there okay well there's a the these
are these are just what I was doing was
saying make a plot of the whole earth
using those those particular projections
and we see it's like the old one there
but again this is the type of type of
sort of curation that is a little
different than what we've what we've
perhaps seen before they're ones where
they're sort of a mixture of of data and
and and models that's something we we
see a lot of oh I don't know let's say
for example standard ocean data there's
a there's a lot of you can you can find
out some I don't know here's here's an
example for instance of a the standard
ocean with a particular salinity and
pressure and temperature and you say
what's the density for the ocean and
that's a that's a kind of a combination
of data and and modeling and so on and
there's there's even other Z v'n the
standard universe if you if you're going
a little them sea universe model data so
this will give you properties of the Big
Bang cosmology and other universe models
and so on a large scale form of data
curation well then there's those
questions of there's always questions
about what can you compute from from the
data so for example let's say you have
Geo data you want to be able to actually
compute things so let's say we want to
get I don't know the travel directions
from I wonder where it thinks we are
right now let's see well who knows let's
find out travel directions from here -
let's say I don't know let's live
dangerously let's say from here to
Buenos Aires so this this should compute
I hope a bunch of travel directions
about how to get from here to
as always let's say we now want to say
make let's just get let's take those
travel directions and let's make a plot
of those okay there we go um okay that's
somewhat plausible I suspect one's
taking a ferry on that some on that part
or we could say for example and we could
we could say for example what's the
travel time assuming you're driving here
and again okay twelve days so again this
is making use of underlying data to do
computations from it there's all sorts
of in for example Geographic data some
kinds of things we've been interested in
oh one one example is historical
countries we've been trying to get a
good collection of kind of the the
structure of all historical countries so
you know the the the idea would be
something like you know the Mongol take
the Mongol Empire and take take that and
try and find the polygon for the Mongol
Empire as of let's say 1250 ad and let's
make a graphic of that for example and
so this should should okay there we go
so there's there's the based on curated
data on historical countries there's the
rather impressive extent of the Mongol
Empire at that time actually that's now
I'm curious about something let's take
the Mongol Empire and let's find the geo
area of the Mongol Empire okay and let's
take that and divide it by the area of
the US so again we'll use natural
language understanding to figure out
that that object okay so at that time it
was about 2.2 times the size of the u.s.
well all kinds of different tongue
different types of data whether it's
some example here well there's there's
all kinds of data that's sort of
cultural data like we've got data on
pokemons and we've got some data on
yoga poses that's one that I find I'm
actually I'm now again I to live which
one I don't know any of these that I I
think is this one that's some see okay
that's a yoga pose okay and let's see we
can actually ask it to sort of disgorge
its complete information on this see
what happens and this is just sort of
looking at the it's taking a while okay
so this is giving oh wow um there's some
okay oh this is actually fun so here
here we've got which muscles are
stretched okay in that particular yoga
pose so let's try and look at some
Anatomy plot 3d see what this works and
let's put those muscles in and let's see
what happens um see it might have to
take it a little while to it'll have to
download some data from the cloud here
but with luck
no no maybe it has to do that for every
single one of those muscles that will be
that will be tiresome but but anyway the
idea here is hopefully that come on
Network load all that stuff I wonder
with all these muscles are nearby well
okay if this takes too long we'll just
do some of them um wake up the I'm
surprised it's it's um it's taking it
quite so long to do this but um I'll
tell you what let's that's ah
oh there we go oh well okay well I guess
that's why I guess that's why Yoga is a
good thing or something no we've got
them
okay so there's um there are a bunch of
muscles I think it took it a while to
download the geometry for all those all
those muscles um so so this is kind of
dealing with um as I'm saying just just
different kinds of data it's important
also to be able to deal not only
explicitly with entities that you would
that you would reference but also
implicitly so so just to show you if I
say something like this that object in
our symbolic language is represented as
an entity of type country and its
canonical name is Italy so for example
if I said I can implicitly reference
something so for example I might say
let's say country and then I might say
population here and then I might say
take largest ten for example and now
what this will do is give me an implicit
list of countries I can say what's the
list of those entities so that's an
implicit list of countries which are the
ten largest by population so that's a
that's a convenient way to do these
kinds of lookups and there's a very
elaborate you can use kind of the whole
Wolfram language to specify those kinds
of queries so for example let's do let's
do something in an area I know little
about but um let's say we say something
like come a you know Pokemon with weight
greater than let's say a hundred
kilograms and
lots of huh okay there are lots of those
well let's say let's just take a random
sample of ten of those for example and
then we could perhaps say let's just do
something like get images of those some
of those ten random big Pokemon okay if
that's you can do all kinds of
scientific studies of those things if
you would like to an example of an area
that's fairly sophisticated from the
point of view of ontology is we've done
a bunch of areas in recent times that
are fairly ontologically complicated one
of them is food
another one is cars food is particularly
nasty because there are many different
variants of things so for example let's
say let's just say I say you know one
cup of orange juice that's something
where um okay this is an instance of a
particular type of food that contains
exactly orange juice and so on I could
for example say take that thing and I
could say synthesize a nutrition label
for that see if that works and I could
do that for any of the probably 50,000
or so foods that we that we now have
available okay so there we go there's
our Nutrition Facts I could if I wanted
to I could say something like um let's
see let's try this let's take our orange
juice there and let's sum let's say how
about we do this
vitamin K per serving for one cup of
orange juice let's say and wake up oh
come on
it's uh hmm odd okay well let's try um
let's try this um got our one cup of
orange juice now let's say something
like vitamin C per serving um hopefully
that will behave my step not behaving
very odd okay let's see um how to do
this let me think um not here let me do
this let me say you just show you just
did this so this will now show us kind
of all the available properties for that
type of for that thing so there's lots
of different things we can work out here
let's say actually now let's pick up
let's pick a weird one molybdenum
content put a typical serving size okay
so now let's say we want to look at
entity so now we're going to implicitly
look entity food molybdenum size per
typical serving size let's say take the
the 10 foods that are largest by
molybdenum size of none okay well let's
pick a different thing let's try it
let's try the the thing I was originally
going for vitamin K the okay so let's do
the 10 foods with the the largest
typical vitamin K okay so we we find
it's kale and it's parsley and and
things like that so this is this is
showing kind of and as I say that we can
get into this in more detail but but
food is an example of an area where
where the ontology is really complicated
because each thing has many variants and
it gets it gets quite gnarly um lots of
different kinds of things again that all
sorts of different kinds of things that
one can curate data about for example
often language has curated data about
itself there are about 5000 functions in
in Wolfram language and we can make
networks that show the relationship
between those and so on because we have
this metadata about about what's what's
there and this is loading really slowly
let's not do that
um well the the question so so that lots
of kinds of curated data that we have
been collecting and and making
computable over the years there's
there's another kind of thing that is
now possible with our cloud which is
easy ways to get data get data into the
system from the outside world and so for
example one thing that exists now is our
data drop and the idea of the data drop
is you get data from pretty much
anywhere and you accumulated in our
cloud and then it becomes easier to
access in the language so you can get
data by you know getting it from a web
api or getting it from rhonda we know or
getting it from if tor or tweeting to it
or whatever else and the end result is
that you will end up with a bunch of
data bins and this may be too slow here
ok so here are a bunch of data bins that
that I've collected for myself let's see
I have no idea what some of these are
but that's let's live dangerously and
pick the very first one here and say
give me a so now what it will do is take
that data bin which is happens to be a
data been owned by me that there are
public data bins and there are own data
pins ok so this is from a little device
that I have on my desk that measures the
measures various properties so each of
these is a time series that I can then
compute from and so the idea again is
this this is data that is coming from
some outside device primarily intended
for things like IOT devices but people
use this a bunch for collecting survey
results and and so on and and have it
then be immediately accessible within
the language I'm actually a new thing
that we recently built is a whole
channel framework that uses sort of
pub/sub mechanisms to make it easy to to
have any kind of
thing that can can open a for example an
HCP based or a mqtt based channel send
data into our cloud and receive data
from our cloud um so the the data bins
are kind of a a way of making use of our
kind of data ontology and within a data
been you can say okay this is pressure
and millibars or something or whatever
that is and it knows you know what the
units are we've curated the ten thousand
different kinds of units that people
people use and you can canonicalize the
data as it comes into the data bin and
that's a that's a very convenient thing
the question is what so add a tab in is
is really mostly a time series or an
event series for other kinds of data a
very convenient mechanism that we've
developed is the thing we call data set
which is kind of a symbolic
generalization of a SQL no SQL database
system so if I say and pick up an
example here um let's see let's pick out
something like how about we do this one
um the so let me just show you an
example of how this works so this is a
data set that's sort of a hierarchical
data set of planets and their moons so
now I can go and start digging into this
data set that's a data set and let's
call that data set let's say D s or
something and now we can say for example
data set all comma comma was that first
thing mass for example and there are the
masses of the planets and now I could
say for example I don't know I could
make some kind of bar chart of those if
I wanted to or I could go and say start
going in and figuring out what the let's
say I want for example all planets and I
want some all planets then moons and
then I want some
see and then I want a histogram of let's
see if I did just do this see if this
okay I don't want to do there is this
okay so that's going to give me the
masses of all moons and now if I wanted
to I could go ahead and flatten that out
and make a histogram of the masses of
all moons and solar system or I could go
and do things like find me the the moons
that are let see what happens if I put
in here it always takes me a moment to
think through exactly how to do this um
okay well I can go ahead and make sort
of arbitrarily complex symbolic queries
against this thing and this thing is a
nice sort of hierarchical structure that
that's dealing with the the kind of the
structure of this data there's a very
very convenient thing that data sets go
back this is a data set that's small
enough it lives in memory we're working
towards having data sets a progressively
larger size file backed database backed
distributed database backed and so on
data sets but all operating with the
same kind of symbolic interface